foreign
Debbie is with us in Charlotte North
Carolina hi Debbie welcome to the Ramsey
Show
thank you for taking
sure what's up
my husband and I have two grown children
our daughter is married and friends from
home independently our son is also grown
but he lives with us but he does pay
rent they both would love to be able to
find homes of their own they've been
unable to do that because of the market
and just their personal finances they
would love to live close to us as we
would love for them to live close to us
as well
so in November some land came available
some acreage came available very close
to us and my husband and I bought it our
home was paid for but we used an old
HELOC that we had there to purchase the
land because we didn't have enough cash
to buy it outright
so since then
um the rates on the HELOC have more than
doubled which means our payment has more
than doubled
um the kids would still we all still
feel the same we all still love for
everybody to be able to build or do
something out there on that land but
financially they're just not ready so my
question is do we refinance this because
the land is paid for but now we're back
in the mortgage situation
um so do we recent answers do we roll it
into a fixed rate mortgage and just work
it paying it off or
do we sell it
wow
what is the land worth
um
how big is your HELOC
uh 250
why did you borrow 50 more than the land
was worth to buy the land when the house
that was just that was a like a business
expense
and the land may be worse than that I'm
sorry a business expense what do you
mean
we have um
a handyman service and the truck that we
use died and so we did use it for that
okay
so you bought a 50 000 truck that you
couldn't afford you bought a 50 000
truck that you couldn't afford and you
bought a 200 000 piece of ground you
couldn't afford
could we not afford it since our home
was paid for it you know the money to
pay for it by definition that means you
couldn't pay afford it if you didn't
have the money to pay for it your your
business is not making enough money to
justify a fifty thousand dollar truck
you know I know that because you didn't
have fifty thousand dollars
yes we did
we did why did you borrow money then
taxes
taxes what's taxes mean
well I mean
if we had no tax deductions then we're
paying more and more and more and more
in taxes do you not know how a tax
deduction works
if you write off ten thousand dollars it
saves you twenty five hundred dollars
you have to give the bank ten thousand
to keep from sending the government 2500
you don't go in debt to create a tax
deduction that's trading a dollar for a
quarter
okay okay um yeah you need to sell the
land
so we've talked to the
case they don't get a vote they're broke
okay so we just need to say
sorry we made a mistake we're going to
sell it that's right because they can't
afford to buy a house this whole this
whole thing that you guys have concocted
not it's not working it's not real yeah
it's not real you've gone into debt for
this you've got bad practices and then
it's all on the stream that the kids are
gonna one day build houses on this land
but you've said they're not ready to no
one is ready and financially able to do
any of the things you're not and they're
not
and so this is a wish it's not a it's
not a realistic prognosis and if you're
sitting on three or four million dollars
and you wanted to play this out then I
would just question whether you're being
an enabler for kids that aren't handling
money well but beyond that we don't even
need to get to that because none of the
three of you have the money to do this
deal and I'll tell you what the next
step was Dave The Next Step was they
would have financed those down payments
for those kids if they could yeah that's
where this is that's where it's headed
heading worse yeah yeah gotta let it go
I'm sorry uh I would not have uh a
mortgage on my home for a piece of land
ever but I for sure wouldn't in this
situation
because it's not got this
family compound dream is probably never
going to happen and if it does it's 10
or 15 years from now and
um it's just not it's not a process you
the kids are going to be much better off
to look to build themselves a
self-sustaining life without mommy and
daddy doing it
and just live nearby that's right all of
my kids live within uh I don't know 30
or 40 minutes of me
um but they don't live in my backyard
none of them would want to probably but
um well there's a certain amount of
pressure that she's that they're placing
on the kids when you say hey I bought
this tract of land then there's also
this okay I guess family you know I've
got I've worked through several family
compound issues over the years and I
don't want one because here's what
happens divorce yeah and now the
ex-daughter-in-law is your next door
neighbor because your son lost the
divorce oh I didn't even
that's not good mom you know uh we gotta
offer to make a half a million dollars a
year more in Seattle so we are leaving
Charlotte
that's what I'm saying and uh guess what
you sell that house to who uh stranger
yeah and the family compound
are strange
strange strangers and you get a strange
stranger as your next door neighbor
right and then now now you know
Thanksgiving really tastes different now
I'm just telling you that these things
don't end well I there some people pull
it off but I'm I've just seen all the
messes and that's if this worked and if
you guys weren't broke Debbie but y'all
are broke none of you have got the money
to pull this off you couldn't even buy
50 000 or you could buy a 50 000 truck
but you didn't so by the way take the
fifty thousand dollars from your
business that you had to buy the truck
with and pay down the home equity loan
so that when the land sells it pays off
the rest of it and put the land on the
market I don't think mama's gonna do
that I don't think she's gonna do it
either but it's the right thing to do it
is shouldn't have called here if you
didn't want the truth